-Big...
[ Laughter ]
Big...
Sorry. Big -- big booty.
-No!
♪♪♪♪
-I will give
each of you a password.
Then each of you
are to give a one-word clue --
one word only -- to get your
partner to guess the password.
If the clue is illegal
as determined by our judges,
you shall hear this.
[ Buzzer ]
And you'll forfeit the turn.
Any questions?
-Well, I was just --
-Okay, great.
First clue goes to
Jennifer and Khloé.
-Mm-hmm.
-The password is...
-Ugh!
-Jennifer,
we're gonna start with you
-No! Why me?!
Ugh!
-Okay. Okay.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yeah.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Okay.
-Big...
[ Laughter ]
Big...
Sorry. Big -- big booty.
-No!
-I'm sorry!
-No. Get your mind
out of the gutter.
-No. Last time --
-I am -- That is --
No, I don't want to hear it.
I do not want to hear it.
That was rude.
-Cool.
-The clue is "cool."
-Oh, I think I...
-Khloé. I don't know.
-No.
Okay, back over to Jennifer.
-Ice.
-Snowstorm.
-No!
3 points. Back to Khloé.
-Oh!
-This barn is on fire.
-Wait.
-Cold.
-Cool, cold.
-Big cold.
Skating rink?
-Skating rink. No.
2 points.
-Can I go again?
-Yes, you can.
Jennifer, 2 points.
-Okay, ready?
-Yeah.
-Watch.
Relaxed.
-Relaxed.
Big, cool, ice.
-Relax.
Big, cool, ice, relax, cold.
Cool --
-Relax!
-Chill!
-Oh!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa!
-I mean...
-Oh, my goodness!
-That was so easy.
-I don't know why.
-That's alright.
-Chill, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"The Big..."
-Alright.
-"The Big Chill"?
-Yeah, that threw me off course.
-Jimmy and Quest.
-Alright, here we go.
-The password is...
-Quest, you will begin.
-Wizzet.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Wizzet.
Wizzet.
-I think she heard you.
-Where is Snoop Dogg
when you need...
-Yeah.
-Aah!
-Got to go.
-I have no idea.
-Okay.
-Rain.
Wizzet. Rain.
No, you said "wizzet."
I didn't say -- You said that.
I said "rain." I said "rain.
He said "wizzet."
I said "rain."
-Wet?
-Wet. No.
No. Back to Quest.
4 points.
-Drizzop.
-What?! What?!
-Oh!
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Judges? Judges?
[ Ding ]
Judges said that
you can still use it?
-Yes. I know I can say that.
Yes.
-Okay. So...
-Okay.
-Drizzop.
Drizzop.
-Rain?
-Rain.
-Yeah, that's it.
That's her guess is "rain.
-I said that.
-That's what I said.
-Oh, you said "rain."
-Alright, it doesn't matter!
Alright, ready?
-I'm so confused.
-[ Laughs ] I can't believ
he got away with that.
I...
Sprizzle.
-Drizzle.
-Yeah! Thank you, thank you.
[ Dinging ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh!
-You're welcome!
You're welcome!
-What?!
-You're welcome.
-Sprizzle.
-What?!
-Oh, my gosh.
Jennifer, Khloé.
-Just a sprizzle.
-Listen...
-The password is...
-Khloé, we're gonna
start with you.
-Stewart.
-Story?
-Stort.
-Stewart.
-Stort? Stewart?
-Stort?
-No, she's saying...
-Am I saying it right?
Stewart.
-Yes.
-Store it? Store it.
-Store it.
-I've never heard of this.
-Stewart.
-Drizzle.
-Stort?
-Stewart.
-Oh, God. Okay. I understand
-Alright, Stewart.
-Stewart.
-Stewer.
-Mouse?
-No.
5 points. Back to Jennifer
-Stort?
I've never heard of these words.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Stewart.
Hot...
-Hot blank.
-Hot Stewart.
-Yes! Yes! You got it.
I saw it in your head.
[ Laughter ]
-No, 'cause I'm thinking
"Hot..."
I'm thinking Rod Stewart.
-Yes!
-"Hot Legs"?
[ Dinging ]
-Hot Rod!
-What did he say?
Hold on.
-[ Laughs ]
-No!
-That's a 10-0!
-That's a shutout! We won!
-Oh!
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sorry.
♪♪♪♪
-I want to thank Jennifer Lopez,
Khloé Kardashian.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will give each of you
a password.
Then you give a one-word -
that's one word only --
clue to your partner
to guess that password.
The team with the most point
after four words wins,
and the first clue goes to..
Noah and Jimmy.
-Here we go.
-The password is...
-Noah, why don't you
start us off.
-Finger. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Finger.
-Only one word?
-Yes. Only one.
-Yeah.
-Can we steal the point?
[ Laughter ]
-You'll have a chance.
-I'm sure you know what finger
-I already know the answer
-Wait.
Can I do another clue now?
-No.
-Oh, okay.
-Shaq knows the answer already
-How?
Did you look at my card?
-It's lickin' good --
finger-lickin' good.
-No, no, no, no.
One word.
-Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
-One word.
-My bad.
-Oh.
-That doesn't count.
-I have another clue now.
-I think you can only
give one word, right?
-Right, one word.
-I'm going to guess middle
-Nice, but no.
-No.
-Nice guess.
-I ruined it.
-No, no, it's okay.
-Jimmy, your turn.
You did not ruin it.
-You didn't ruin it.
-Okay.
-Jimmy's going to ruin it.
-So one clue is "finger."
It's one word back.
-Has to be pinkie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, whoa, whoa!
Shaq attack!
-It has to be pinkie.
-Oh, my gosh, that's nuts!
-Has to be pinkie, man,
if it's not -- Yeah, he's right.
-To Shaq and Mandy.
-Alright, Mandy.
-The password is...
-Shaq, you are up first.
-Okay, buddy.
You can do this.
[ Laughter ]
-Hump.
-Sorry?
[ Laughter ]
-Hump. Hump.
The man said "hump."
-You said "hump"?
-Hump.
H-U-M-P.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hump.
Humpty hump.
Wednesday?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-That's a good guess.
-No. That's a good guess.
-That's legitimate.
-That is officially hump day
-Okay.
You heard...
-Hump.
-...hump.
Toe.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh, snap!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Camel toe?
-Yo!
[ Dinging ]
-Oh, ho-ho-ho!
It's a family show.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Is that legal?
-I don't know.
-That's legal.
-I don't know if that's legal.
-Oh, come on.
-That's legal, that's legal.
Alright, Noah and Jimmy,
it's your --
-Well done.
-The password is...
-Alright, Jimmy,
why don't we start off with you.
-Alright.
-You go. Don't say "hump."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause --
-Say it again.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause --
-♪♪ 'Cause this is thriller
[ Dinging ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
Oh!
-That was it?
-That's it, yeah.
-What did he say?
-'Cause --
'Cause --
That's all --
That's all we can clear, too
-Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, don't say any more.
Okay.
-'Cause --
That's it.
-The final clue.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was amazing.
-Can't believe
you got that one, man.
-Alright, Shaq.
-The password is...
-It's 5-11.
-Okay.
-You can tie this up.
-You're going down.
-No, no, this is it right here
I feel it.
-5-11?
Where did that come from?
-Odd math, this game.
-Yeah.
-You looked at it.
-I did.
-Okay. Okay.
-Ready?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, they're in the zone.
-I --
-Yeah, what are --
-Okay.
-They got in the zone there.
-Yeah. AutoZone.
-Ruff.
-Dog.
-No. Alright.
-You just woofed.
[ Laughter ]
-Shaq.
-Wait, what?
-[ Growling ]
-Aah!
-Ruff.
-Okay. What is it?
Use your thinking cap.
No.
That's not it.
-Jimmy, hurry up.
I think I know.
-They have a bond.
They have a psychic bond.
-Bone?
-Ooh!
-Pit bull.
-No.
-Oh.
-Hold on.
-[ Barking ]
-Wait a second.
Mandy's going to give a clue
-Can I give a clue?
Can I give a clue?
-No, no, she answered.
-She answered already.
-I jumped the gun.
It doesn't count.
-And she was wildly off.
-Go ahead.
-Let her have one clue.
-Well, he went...
-Okay, ready?
Mandy, it's your turn.
-I didn't mean
to mess your suit up.
-Hey, don't worry about it
-Slobber.
-Ruff and tree.
-Put this on eBay.
-What?
-Alright.
-What? Tree?
-Huh?
-What?
-Do I get a lifeline?
-No, you can't have a lifeline
-No.
-Ruff?
-Ruff and tree?
-Yeah.
You've heard "ruff" is one clue.
And now the second word
she's giving you is "tree.
-Wood.
-What's that? Wood?
-I said "wood."
I don't know.
-Because wood is rough,
and it comes from a tree.
Alright.
-For the win -- bark!
-Bark.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Laughs ]
My thanks to Mandy Moore,
Noah Cyrus,
Shaquille O'Neal, the champ!